welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast today's
episode starts by paying tribute to a
powerlifting legend then Greg shares
some benchpress tips with us followed by
a discussion on time restricted feeding
or intermittent fasting to play us out
Greg answers a listeners question about
common mistakes that coaches made when
coaching beginners finally we've got a
great interview with dr. grant tins
grant is a professor at Texas Tech
University and he sat down with us to
talk about some of his research on body
composition physique athletes and
intermittent fasting as always thank you
for listening and enjoy the show
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your host Eric Trexler
today I am joined by a temporary guest
host named Greg knuckles and as our
listeners know we did in facts come out
with the first ever fitness podcast
which has garnered us a great deal of
attention on the Internet and Greg you
came up with a really nice idea to kind
of put that newfound attention to use
kind of a new service I guess you'd say
yeah so we're we're trying to stay at
the cutting edge of the field in terms
of the products and services that we
provide for our listeners and readers so
a lot of the people in our audience are
fitness professionals one of the
toughest things about doing fitness
stuff online is accruing an audience in
the first place I think most people
would agree to that comes easily to some
people but for a lot of people there's a
grind of multiple years just to get
enough eyes on your content that you can
sell enough coaching sell enough
products just to make ends meet so we
figured how about we launched a service
that will fast tracked that process for
online content producers so when you
look around there are a multitude of
people whose entire online business
model revolves around generating
controversy they call people out they
just generally start a stink and that's
how they keep eyes on their content and
if you have been paying attention to
that you'll know that drama works best
when there's multiple parties involved
if person a calls person B out in person
B fires back then that gets both of the
audience's involved there's some some
cross-pollination going on that's when
fitness industry beef is at its most
effective however most people are a
little bit too agreeable to initiate
beef with other content producers online
and it's hard to know if you call
someone out are they gonna take the bait
is it going to end up being a beneficial
beef transaction as it were so we
decided
we would launch a service where you can
sign up for the low low price of one
9999 per month we were less than $200
correct very much less we will pair you
with someone else who we think would be
ideal for you to start beef with they
will also be paired with you
you guys can then exchange contact
information discuss your strategy decide
what you want to call each other out on
exactly what shots you're gonna take
then you can initiate your online beef
that'll get a lot of eyes on your
content if it's messy enough it
theoretically could go viral and that's
the goal here so that's the basic level
of our service if you're willing to
upgrade to four 9999 per month which is
less than $500 correct very much so
you can actually start beef with us
directly we have obviously the first
fitness podcast we have many millions of
downloads per month that will give you
access to a large and one might even say
burgeoning audience with whom you can
showcase your beefing ability because
that seems to be the primary skill set
that actually matters in the fitness
industry these days so yeah we just
figured you know you give us your time
every week to listen to our podcast we
want to give back to you with this
service that will help you grow your
online following through the the
time-tested strategy of talking [ __ ] on
social media in the most efficient and
effective way possible yeah I mean right
now it looks like the big thing is a lot
of people are trying to get hired to
coach people how to be fitness coaches
but they're doing a bunch of boring
stuff they're talking about like
advertising and funnels and email lists
and stuff that's stuff so boring yeah
this will make sure that people see some
some level of your personality anyone
can get out there and say oh look I'm
strong I have good abs I can be a
fitness coach but that doesn't that
doesn't show the audience your
personality which is ultimately what
people are going to connect with what
does let people see your personality
really put your best foot
or at least a foot forward talking a
bunch of [ __ ] online that is that is how
you do it these days you may not like it
but that is what peak business looks
like absolutely now normally on a normal
episode now we would do feats of
strength but unfortunately there was we
lost a legend in the strength world so
Greg won't you give us an update on that
yeah so changing gear super hard gene
rich flack died this past week or
probably about two weeks ago by the time
you're listening to this a lot of people
have already said a lot of words about
him we probably wouldn't really be able
to add to that all that much I didn't
have a personal relationship with him
I don't believe Eric did either but what
I will say is that this isn't just you
know just being polite to someone
because they died I legitimately did not
ever hear anyone say anything bad about
gene didn't hear anyone say anything bad
about how he ran his meets he was the
founder of the RPS and that is actually
pretty noteworthy because he was
probably biggest in the era of
powerlifting that was probably the most
toxic everyone just constantly talking
[ __ ] about everyone else in powerlifting
never heard anyone say anything bad
about gene which is notable because he
was one of the most visible power
lifters of his era he was the first guy
to bench over a thousand equipped back
in 2004 I believe and he he looms large
in my mind in terms of my own personal
powerlifting history because he was the
bench record holder when I got into the
sport so he was like looking up to his
numbers is one of the first things I
remember doing as a power lifter but
yeah great lifter by all accounts I've
heard great guy great meat director so
yeah the the powerlifting community law
lost a pillar today or recently yeah and
it's tough on our show because we spend
our time on the show either talking
about something stupid or trivial you
know we joke around a lot we talk about
things that are like hey how do you
benchpress more so it's hard to put
things on the show that actually deserve
a lot of gravity and kind of a solemn
attitude so a very genuine heartfelt
rest in peace in the interest of the
feats of strength segments in general
kind of like in memoriam do we have any
of his like top lifting numbers of
all-time on hand yeah so he he was the
first person to bench over a thousand
equipped Scott Mendelsohn took his
record in 2008 I believe with hurt 2006
with a thousand an eight pound bench and
then gene took the record back about a
year later with a thousand and ten and I
believe that may have been the most
heated in competition I I think he hung
it up after that and started running his
Federation and being a meat promoter
full-time after that he also a lot of
people don't know this as a is someone
primarily known as a bench specialist
gene also earlier in his career was a
three left power lifter as well he also
squatted over a thousand in gear back
back in the era of multiply we're pretty
good depth was actually enforced so yeah
he had a he had a quite legit looking
thousand pound multiply squad as well so
not just a big venture really good
all-around lifter which obviously
matters dramatically less than the
legacy he left with the sport as a
person and a meat director but yeah he
was not just a great venture but but a
pretty good all-around lifter as well
you know great lifter great guy big loss
for powerlifting as a community so
switching gears we have a segment on the
show called coach's corner where we
focus on some
applied tips that you can use in your
own training or with your clients that
you coach and today Gregg has a couple
of tips for the bench press yeah in
honor of Jean we figured it was only
fitting that the that the coaching tips
today were bench press related so the
first one is super basic the second one
sounds weird but it is worth
experimenting with so tip number one
this so you're gonna hear it you're
gonna think that sounds so basic it's
stupid but just give it a shot
it tends to not necessarily make someone
have perfect bench press form but as
long as someone set up is pretty decent
they can get a tight arch get decent leg
drive like as long as everything from
the shoulders down works pretty well for
their bench press this tends to clean up
the rest just squeezing the bar as hard
as you possibly can irons out a lot of
the inefficiencies people have with
their bench press technique if you if
you conscious so you don't have to
squeeze the bar on bench it will sit in
your hands due to gravity and you don't
particularly have to squeeze it hard so
a lot of people don't and when you see
when you see most really elite level
ventures there's virtually no wasted
movement everything looks tight smooth
locked in but kind of a level down you
can see people then is still bench
pretty solid weights but everything just
looks a little bit shaky ER and like
they're in a little bit less control of
the load the the lines the bar takes
isn't as clean maybe their elbows kind
of wobble a little bit instead of just
very smoothly like locking out the way
they're supposed to
so just squeezing the bar as hard as
possible will help you create more
tension in your upper body generally
help give people a cleaner bar path and
just stay tighter and waste less
movement in the bench press
in in that the like I said it sounds
really basic and dumb but I've seen that
very simple cue clean up a lot of
technical errors of people who more or
less have the movement down but still
just kind of seem shaky and not
completely in control of the movement
okay and the second tip I have is for
people who have lockout problems in the
bench press so most people if they're
going to fail a bench press they're
going to fail it kind of in the
mid-range of the lift or slightly below
the midpoint of the lift there are some
people however who very consistently
fail at lockout they'll get the bar you
know 95% of the way up but they just
can't finish locking out their elbows
which honestly makes no sense just from
a pure tricep strength perspective and
often times when people have lockout
issues they'll just hammer tricep work
and it doesn't actually go anywhere and
doesn't fix much for them and something
I found that helps a lot and obviously
you can't do this on rep work but maybe
just on the last rep of a set or if
you're going for a 1 rep max if you're
almost there a lockout and the bar just
won't go up that last inch or two for
you something that helps a lot is is
what I call falling into the bench kind
of letting letting your arch go and
letting your scapula protract I found
that that helps a lot of people finish
locking out the bench press
if they fail right there the very very
top the reason why I think that is is so
your humerus articulates with your
scapula or your scapula and so when your
scapula are super super retracted and
you're almost at lockout you're you're
you're to a point where you're in a
pretty decent amount of horizontal
adduction at that point and if you just
let your scapula protract all you don't
really have to change
the angle of your shoulder all that much
like you don't have to do further
horizontal adduction but basically if
you can just hold the bar where it is
and fall like two inches into the bench
it locks out for you I think it may have
something to do with scapula humeral
rhythm so essentially if you weren't
bench pressing like you know if you were
say throwing a punch when your fist is
cocked back at your shoulder your
scapula or your scapula is probably
going to be pretty protracted and then
when you're nearing full extension and
you're about to make contact with the
other person's face your scapula is
probably going to be pretty protracted
just to reiterate retracted when the
when you're pulling the punch back and
then protract did I say protract yeah
yeah yeah when you're pulling the punch
back scapula retracted when you're about
to actually make contact scapula
protracted like that's that's the way
movements like that would tend to work
if your scapula aren't pinned into a
bench press so I think I think that may
be what's doing it for you
when you're near lockout in a bench
press if you were say doing something
like a push up your scapula would just
naturally protract as you go through
that range of motion and so you know
maybe that's what does it I I'm not
saying for sure that is the mechanism
but I've seen that be very very helpful
to a lot of people who have that
specific lockout problem so I'm not
talking about someone who can clear the
mid-range and eventually fails on the
bench you know four inches from lockout
I'm talking about the type of person who
if they miss a bench press rep it's
always like just the last inch or two
before lockout so falling into the bench
letting your arch collapse a little bit
and protracting your shoulders helps
those people a lot one one note that
I'll make is a lot of people hear that
and they think oh well I retract my
scapula to protect my shoulders when I
bench protracting that sounds super
dangerous I don't want to do that the
whole point of retracting your scapula
is to protect your shoulders at the
bottom of the rep so if your protracting
at the top your shoulders aren't it very
much risk in that position in the first
place so you know I'm not talking about
doing all of your reps with your scapula
protracted I'm talking about just the
very last rep up maybe a rep max set or
when going for a max just at the very
top letting your your scapula protract
your arch collapse and basically not
trying to press the bar any further but
hold it in that position and fall into
the bench about an inch or two to
complete the lockout and at that point
since it's happening at the end of the
lift it's basically you've gotten
everything you needed out of that upper
back tightness for that rep you could
fall back into the Ben tree they're
gonna get it or you're not at that point
now I did have one question about your
first bench tip about squeezing the bar
now sometimes when I have wrist or hand
issues um I will transition to a false
grip some people call it a suicide grip
can you still apply that with the false
grip or do you generally advise against
the false grip in general I'm actually
glad you asked about that because that
is something I meant to say actually I
asked good question sometimes yeah well
maybe so but no that is actually
something that I meant to mention and
forgot to so an another question that I
get pretty frequently is how do I keep
my wrists from cocking back when I bench
press if you just squeeze the [ __ ] out
of the bar it generally will keep your
wrists from cocking back very much
so your your finger flexors and like
your hand flexors and your wrist flexors
share a common tendon they share the
same origin and so when you but if
you're listening to this just try this
really quick it won't be super obvious
if there are people around but [ __ ] your
wrist back as far as you can and then
from that position make the tightest
fist you can possibly make that is going
to decock your wrist and bring it not
maybe completely back to neutral but
back towards a neutral position so yeah
people who have is
choose with their risk Hawking when they
bench squeezing the ever-loving crap out
of the bar helps pretty substantially
with that and so to your question Eric
people have wrist issues when they bench
for possibly a couple different reasons
a lot of them do just relate to their
wrist cocking back a lot when they bench
and so I don't necessarily think you
could squeeze as hard with a false grip
but if you have just a normal grip and
squeeze really hard that may get rid of
the need for a false grip the other the
other potential reason why someone may
have wrist discomfort is they may have
medial wrist discomfort or I guess from
anatomical position that would be
lateral wrist discomfort but on the
thumb side of your wrist yeah if you're
if you're taking a really wide grip on
the bar you can get some discomfort on
the thumb side of your wrist if you're
pinching a tendon squeezing the bar
super hard probably isn't going to help
much with that and people who take a
false grip that allows them to shift
more towards almost like a pseudo
neutral grip probably the false grip
which would still be a better call there
but yeah if you're maybe getting some
wrist discomfort because because your
wrists are cocking back a lot when you
bench just squeezing the bar really hard
it helps a lot with that issue as well
now for today's episode we have a really
good interview with Grant Tinsley he is
a professor at Texas Tech University and
he's done a lot of the really cool
applied work on intermittent fasting and
so because we have his interview today
we wanted to take a little look at kind
of the history of intermittent fasting
what the studies have shown us so far
and then we want to talk about his most
recent study which actually came out
this very month so before we get into
the research on it Greg you've been in
the industry a hell of a lot longer than
I have
I basically just kind of checked out for
a minute there and just lived in a
basement lab it's dim didn't pay
attention
so can you give a little background of
the the fitness industry's history with
intermittent fasting yeah so this
probably won't be a complete history for
that
Eric Helms would probably be the guy to
talk to he's he's more like the iron
sport historian but in terms of the
recent history of intermittent fasting
in the fitness industry several years
ago so I don't know maybe eight ten
years ago the three people who were
really promoting intermittent fasting a
lot where Martin birkin lean gains calm
Brad Pilon
I think his website was called eat stop
eat calm I know the book he sold was
called eat stop eat and Ori Hoffer
Meckler of the warrior diet and I'm sure
that there were people promoting
intermittent fasting prior to them but
basically the fitness industry prior to
that was almost synonymous with the
bodybuilding industry and for for like a
good spicy 20 years or so the
bodybuilding practice was you know you
need to eat 37 meals a day yeah spaced
them out by at most 20 minutes you know
basically you you want to be putting
something in your face at all times and
so I'm sure that there were you know
profits crying out in the wilderness
saying hey you don't actually have to
eat all like constantly but birkin Brad
Pilon and Ori Hoffer Meckler were the
first people that I remember being able
to cut through that noise and make what
many people found to be a persuasive
case for not having to live out of
Tupperware the burhan approach was
everyday having a 16 hour fasting period
in an 8 hour feeding window which
basically just equated to skipping
breakfast Brad Pilon eat stop eat
approach was essentially to eat normally
most days and then once or twice per
week have
24-hour fasts or basically you would
fast from dinner one day until dinner
the next day and then just eat normally
otherwise and Ori Hoffer Meckler his
approach was similar to Birkins approach
but instead of an 18 hour fast or a 16
hour fast an 8 hour feeding window it
was a 20 hour fast and a four hour
feeding window but other than that the
the general principles were pretty
similar so those were the people
promoting intermittent fasting I should
note that there were a lot of people
into fitness who at least some of the
time we're doing intermittent fasting
forever
and those were Muslims who were into
lifting who during Ramadan take a very
reverse intermittent fasting approach
where rather than skipping breakfast or
breakfast and lunch essentially they
would eat a big dinner maybe a big
breakfast depending when they got up and
then fast throughout the day so
depending on how you define terms here
you may see that as more of a time
restricted feeding approach than
intermittent fasting those two terms are
effectively synonymous these days it
does Ramadan brings such a interesting
challenge I know somebody who was doing
the sport nutrition for a very high
level national soccer team and the
majority if not all of the athletes wore
Muslim and it was it was such a cool
look at like how to get creative with
sport nutrition of trying to navigate
that as a practitioner during a
competitive season it's the water that
gets you yeah yeah that's the water yeah
yeah so I mean before Birkin and Pilon
and HOF McClure were promoting it like
there were obviously probably millions
of people into Fitness who did at least
occasionally intermittent fast yeah so
the those were the guys that really got
the ball rolling these days Andy Morgan
I think has become
more synonymous with intermittent
fasting on ripped body calm even though
he doesn't write about it quite as much
anymore
let's see Greg o Gallagher Kino body is
is probably the person who maybe not our
audience would know the best but
probably just in Fitness generally
people would these days associate the
most with intermittent fasting because
of his what was it like the real Bruce
Wayne YouTube ads ran very like
cinematic yeah too bad yeah and then
someone who kind of flies under the
radar but who whose work on intermittent
fasting I think Warren sir Reid is Boyan
kostov ski he used to run the site lift
heavy net I believe that site has gone
belly-up and he works for a company
called I believe lamda Fitness or lambda
training these days but he wrote oh man
he wrote like an eighty thousand word
essentially book on all of the human and
animal research on intermittent fasting
that had been published up to 2012 the
he published it in 2012
I checked the site prior to a starting
recording and he said he's working on an
update that hopefully should be out at
some point in 2019 but even what he
wrote in 2012 is still one of the more
comprehensive things about intermittent
fasting that I've read so yeah that's
that's kind of how we got to now in in
intermittent fasting in the fitness
industry and in the one of the things
that's really challenging with
intermittent fasting when you start
looking at the research side of things
is kind of a big hang-up when it comes
to terminology and so if you look up
intermittent fasting research you're
probably gonna find something that does
not approximate what you had in mind
it's typically like alternate day
fasting right correct yeah so yeah in
the research world time restricted
feeding would you know the idea of own
having like an 8 hour feeding window or
something like that they call it time
restricted feeding in the research
literature because they kind of got beat
to the punch when it comes to using the
term intermittent fasting the the
earlier research that kind of grabbed
that term really looked at very
different approaches then then a
shortened daily feeding window so that
usually took one of a few formats when
we talk about intermittent fasting in
the research so the simplest one is just
alternate day fasting you eat one day
you don't eat the next and so on and so
forth other study protocols have done
like a 2 day like a 48 hour fast that
goes somewhere in the week and it's just
a weekly 48 hour fast a third approach
that's kind of common in the research is
having 2 24-hour fasts basically placed
somewhere within the week that's what I
think Brad Pilon based his approach on
yeah yeah so if you ask someone in the
fitness in their industry what is
intermittent fasting they're gonna tell
you oh you only eat for eight hours a
day or something like that and I think
most people would would give you that
definition yeah so the only reason I
bring that up is if you look at the
literature you'll have to keep your eyes
peeled for time restricted feeding
rather than just intermittent fasting
and you really have to look at what
exactly they mean when they're
describing that intervention now a lot
of the studies on these research
approaches of intermittent fasting of
taking a full day or two days or every
other day of complete fasting those days
are usually carried out in overweight or
obese people they're usually not engaged
in exercise training of any type and
generally speaking those studies are
oriented toward looking at fat loss
that's pretty much the name of the game
there have been enough of those studies
that they're actually I believe at least
three meta analyses that have been
published kind of summarizing the entire
body of literature mm-hmm generally
speaking what those meta analyses show
with a VAT approach is it works better
than nothing
which is good but it doesn't really work
better than just a normal
run-of-the-mill caloric deficit so in
terms of the fat loss outcomes in the
general weight loss outcomes it's a
completely suitable way to lose weight
but it doesn't seem to confer much and a
much of an advantage compared to a more
moderate just normal everyday caloric
deficit yeah I think I think one of
those meta-analyses reported maybe
slightly better fat loss and one of them
reported maybe slightly better lean mass
retention but when you actually dig into
it the actual magnitudes of those
effects were pretty small yet to the
point that well it's statistically
significant but who actually cares right
yeah yeah I remember like one time back
in the day I was looking at a study I'm
like maybe CLA in the supplement it was
for fat loss oh that's a that's a blast
from the past yeah yeah I was looking at
a study and you know that was all over t
nation's front page in like 2009 yeah
yeah that's when I was really into
something because it gets my shredded so
my skit yeah so of course it gets human
shredded okay but I remember I saw this
study that people were like finally the
definitive proof that it helps with fat
loss and it was like you had to take it
for like 120 days mm-hmm like God knows
how much money you spent on those pills
and after that entire span of time it
was like an extra point eight kilograms
of fat loss and it's like dude just eat
like three less bytes of food a day hey
yeah and save like a hundred bucks on
pills and you're good that that's
honestly wild to me because you can you
can express that in terms of how much is
each pound of fat balls worth to you and
so that's like an additional pound and a
half of fat loss right and if you're
talking 120 days you know that's
probably for yeah I'm going off memory
which my memory sucks but it was
something alive I'm just assuming that
you've remembered correctly okay very
dangerous biggest big assumption a hard
caveat yeah so and I remember bottles of
CLA pills like a monthly supply would be
about 20 25 bucks so let's say you're
spending
eighty dollars over those four months
for an extra pound and a half of fat
loss you're essentially saying each
extra pound of fat losses worth 50 bucks
to you right
that's wild bad bet and again I want to
be very clear greg's these are
essentially arbitrary numbers because my
memory is trash
the general concept was it was a long
ass study the magnitude was super tiny
and then the numbers just didn't work
it's like okay great so you're paying a
ton of money over a ton of time mm-hmm
for a few hundred grams of fat mass loss
yeah just not worth it but anyway there
are now studies emerging that look at
the more fitness industry kind of
approach which we'll call time
restrictive feedings so the idea is
you're still eating every day but you're
restricting the time within the day that
you're eating meals usually it's gonna
be like an eight hour feeding window
give or take mmm-hmm now a couple of the
early studies there were a couple one
was by grant Tinsley his first study on
the topic another by Gil at all there
are a couple these these studies
basically opted not to match for caloric
intake and that's not a bad thing
necessarily now what they found was that
essentially time restricted feeding is a
very nice way to indirectly reduce your
caloric intake so I mean these were
completely suitable approaches for
weight loss and fat loss but that's not
a magic effect right it's like if you
happen to restrict your your time window
of feeding you generally tend to eat a
little bit less and that's pretty cool
yeah I remember when I don't remember as
much chatter about the Gil study but I
remember when grants study was published
so many people jumped on it
and they were like oh this is trash
research they didn't even match calorie
intake and it's like dude most of the
people promoting their mint and fasting
say that it's an easy way to consume
fewer calories because you're eating
sometimes fewer times and just generally
spending less of the day thinking about
food like it it was some people were
promoting it as magic via growth hormone
which I don't think they fully
understand but yeah most of the people
promoting it were were just saying hey
this is an easy way to naturally consume
fewer calories or to be less hungry
while consuming fewer calories so he
does a study finds oh lo and behold
people consume less calories people were
like yeah they didn't match calorie
intake [ __ ] stupid like yeah yeah
whatever I mean that's that's what he
was looking for yeah yeah yeah
now the middle ground is where it sucks
so you either take the approach and say
we're not going to my match calories
because that's part of the magic here
mm-hmm is the satiety and the lower
caloric intake the other approaches
we're gonna very strictly match calories
and see if there's any physiological
magic going on the worst of both worlds
is let's try to match them but in free
living subjects with self-reported
nutrition intake because it gives you
the guise of the idea that that caloric
intake was controlled but realistically
it probably wasn't yeah and so that
that's where another study by Mauro at
all kind of fell in the middle there and
it is it's not to discredit their work
or to bash them for it but it really was
kind of right in that middle ground of
we're gonna try to control it but not
with enough rigor to feel confident
about it and so the results really kind
of fell in line with exactly what you
would expect so the control group gained
point two kilograms over the eight-week
study the the time restricted feeding
group lost about a kilogram and when you
start digging through the paper you
start to see like there's probably a
good likelihood that they just ate
probably a little bit less yeah and
that's kind of kind of what happened now
the other end of that spectrum is a
study by stoked Sutton so stoat did a
little had a little bit more rigorous
control in terms of the caloric intake
what they did was
they kind of met them halfway so it
wasn't completely free living subjects
they gave the subjects dinner and they
provided an intact breakfast and lunch
but one of the problems was the subjects
that were doing the time restricted
feeding they kind of struggled to finish
their dinners mm-hmm when they were
being supervised so it is halfway
between like hey live in the metabolic
Ward for the whole study it was like why
don't you come by for dinner we'll pack
you up a goodie bag and you take that
home for your other meals um but but one
of the issues was the time restricted
fene group because of the satiety effect
of staggering meal intake that way they
actually were really struggling to
finish their dinners and so it probably
confounded the results a little bit
again only if you're concerned with
finding some kind of magic when calories
are matched in practical terms that's
still a win you know it's like yeah
you're on a weight loss diet or at least
like a small weight loss diet they
weren't like shedding weight but you
could barely get your food in because of
this meal timing strategy yeah if fat
loss is a goal then that's a really nice
thing to happen mm-hmm so what happened
was the subjects when they were in that
time restricted feeding intervention
they lost 1.4 kilograms over the
eight-week intervention but they did
consume 65 fewer calories per day so the
numbers don't completely add up but but
those 65 fewer calories per day I
believe is based mostly on their
inability to finish dinner I would
imagine there's some possibility that
some of the non supervised meals might
have also had some unaccounted for
caloric shortcomings in the time
restricted feeding group but in any case
you know it it was it was a slight
benefit but again it really looks like
the satiety is really what is driving
the effect of these different
intermittent fasting interventions
mm-hmm now there was a study by Sutton
at all that was very well controlled so
every single meal was prepared by the
laboratory and consumed
in the lab under direct supervision and
they used a crossover design which meant
that every subject served as their own
control which is in any kind of
physiology study is a really nice thing
because you don't have to worry about
all the million things that could differ
between the people in that group and the
other group just at random so what they
were trying to do was actually keep them
at their normal body weight so they were
adjusting the caloric intake they tried
to keep it matched so that over these
five week feeding periods they would
just stay weight stable they wanted to
look at the effects of shifting these
feeding windows in the absence of fat
loss and basically what happened was
when they tried to make that work and
theoretically you would think if there's
no magic going on they would both kind
of stay weight stable during the
intervention what happened was the time
restricted feeding group was did end up
half a kilogram lighter or when the
subjects did the time restricted
restricted feeding intervention compared
to the other one mm-hmm
because it wasn't two different groups
it was the same people yeah but they
were half a kilogram lighter after the
time restricted feeding intervention but
the authors basically said we could
probably attribute that to just glycogen
storage based on when we did the
measurements and when their last meal
was yeah so generally speaking when you
look at the time restricted time
restricted feeding literature I think
it's safe to say that if you're a person
who struggles with satiety or struggles
with overeating I think this is a damn
good strategy to try to curb that now
the thing where the place where it gets
tricky is if calories are equal is a
time restricted feeding intervention
gonna help you lose more fat than a
normal meal distribution I'm not
convinced of that yet and one of the
reasons I'm not convinced of that yet is
because no one has really put forward a
really solid mechanism and actually
provided evidence for that so people
have said well maybe it affects resting
under
expenditure or total energy expenditure
but the literature doesn't really
consistently show that some of the
researchers have suggested maybe
adiponectin is playing a role there but
again very inconsistent in the
literature so no one has really showed a
study where there's a clear benefit of
the time restricted feeding in the
absence of just eating fewer calories
and no one has really shown a real
airtight solid mechanism that would
suggest why there would be some
meaningful effect there yeah yeah I mean
it's um so when we talk about something
like say hypertrophy or strength gains
there's a fair amount of wishy-washy
nough stare just because a lot of that
depends on your genetics just generally
how well you respond to training but
when you're talking about weight loss or
fat loss or when you're talking about
weight change and body composition
change then you're moving into the range
you're moving into the realm of dealing
with pretty straightforward physics and
things that are understood quite well
and so if you're if you know you're
consuming the exact same amount of
calories if you're expecting to lose
more fat one of two things can be
happening either energy expenditure is
increasing like you said and there's not
evidence for that or you're you're
having maybe like a shift in respiratory
exchange ratio where you're biasing fat
burning but they're burning more fat is
going to be it has to be offset by using
less lean mass and so essentially if you
want to make an argument for something
being better for fat loss you need a CO
argument for that same thing being
better for gaining or retaining lean
mass more effectively and like you said
there's to this point not been a
possible mechanism for that other than
oh maybe people lose a little more fat
because they actually end up consuming a
little bit less yeah and again that's
not a knock on the intervention there's
a damn good intervention you know it
makes you eat less yeah awesome very
good what one other mechanism that's
been thrown out I just don't want to
omit it in the interest of completeness
but one group of researchers suggested
that during the fasting period there's
an e flux of free fatty acids from fat
cells they were thinking that might
increase gluconeogenesis which is a
energetically fairly inefficient means
of creating ATP for creating
carbohydrate but that just doesn't mesh
up well with the studies that actually
directly measured different components
of energy expenditure you know if there
was this inefficiency theoretically
you'd be able to figure that out yeah
and it's not just that that would also
still show up as energy expenditure
because right yeah when you're talking
about something not being metabolically
efficient you're talking about losing
energy as heat during some right
conversion process so yeah if you're
saying that you know you're getting a
lot of gluconeogenesis and that's
metabolically inefficient and that
causes greater fat loss that would have
to show up as a measurable increase in
energy expenditure which it doesn't
exactly now the question that comes up
with a lot of people that are into
fitness is you know with meal frequency
you alluded to this back in the day
every body builder carried around like
eight things a tupperware you had to eat
every couple hours to keep your
metabolism revved up substantial
research has shown that to be a total
myth it's just not it's just not how it
is the meal timing or the meal frequency
conversation then shifted toward
essentially how do we maintain muscle
protein balance and then people were
less worried about frequent meals to
keep their metabolic rate up but more
worried about how do I make sure I'm
initiating spikes and muscle protein
synthesis throughout the day and the
idea was you know based on some research
we see that you you give a solid bolus
of protein when I say solid I mean
sizable not literally solid but you give
a bolus of protein you increase protein
synthesis for a certain amount of time
in the immediate period following that
there's what they call the refractory
period where another bolus of protein
will not necessarily some eight or give
an additional stimulus for protein
synthesis so the idea was you want to
have multiple spikes throughout the day
but they can't be too close together so
you want to spread them evenly and so
what that what most people would would
recommend from that viewpoint would be
anywhere between three to six three to
five three to six equally spaced meals
from the moment you wake up to the
basically before you go to bed you want
to space them as much as you can and
still get several in while having at
least like three ish hours between them
now that's an approach that is totally
at odds with time restricted feeding and
so a lot of people have said well this
time restricted feeding seems to be
great for enhancing satiety which could
help me stay leaner and feel more
satisfied on a calorie restricted diet
but am I going to sacrifice muscle gains
or am I going to lose muscle from
implementing that strategy that's the
question that's been on a lot of
people's minds I think for quite some
time and that's where grant tensley's
new study comes into play so this is a
study in resistance trained females they
were on a time restricted feeding
protocol where they had all their meals
within an eight hour period and they
were being compared to a control group
that was just eating their normal
schedule and throughout this diet
protocol they were doing eight weeks of
resistance training now in the interest
of time I'm not going to get into all
the details about exactly what they did
but the good news is if you look in the
September 2019 issue of mass I am going
to do a very very deep thorough review
of the study I'm going to get into all
the details of exactly what they did it
exactly what they found and exactly what
that means for you but for today's
podcast I'm just going to very briefly
summarize the findings which essentially
showed that the feeding schedule did not
meaningfully influence the adaptations
to resistance training when it came to
performance or body composition and
normally with with a study out comes a
study where the outcomes are generally
null and there's no difference between
groups you go odds and at work in this
case I think a lot of people who
advocate for time restrictive feeding
probably had a sigh of relief because
because the big concern was are you
missing out on hypertrophy or are you
gonna fail to retain lean mass by having
this restrictive feeding window so in
this case null results are actually
pretty alright when it comes to the time
restricted versus the normal feeding
window so when we talk about meal timing
I think the general recommendation I
always give people like my clients that
I coach I say it'd be great if you had
at least three protein containing meals
if you space them throughout the day
great but but we need three of them and
preferably there'll be at least a few
hours apart from each other I think
three is a nice minimum number if you
had two is that gonna be the end of your
goals with that diet or training program
probably not it's not the end of the
world you'll be fine
but this study kind of lends a little
bit of confidence to people who are
worried about the idea that if you don't
have protein upon waking and then three
more times throughout the day and then
right before bed you can still have
similar adaptations to it to a
resistance training program yeah now one
thing to keep in mind there was a paper
that came out this month by bin Naha
Rudin at all sure it's closed it's
called breakfast omission reduces
subsequent resistance exercise
performance and so what they did was
they look at spoiler alert I know and
right in the title but what they did was
pretty pretty straightforward
after an overnight fast they either gave
a breakfast or they just had them drink
some water
did resistance training and what they
found was that omitting breakfast in
this case in people who normally ate
breakfast performance was significantly
impaired by the lack of breakfast we
need to put an alert out to these
scientists where we as lowly podcasters
are trying to as the kids say drop
knowledge bombs on our listeners and
part of that involves us being able to
be the ones delivering information to
the listeners and when you give the game
away in the title of your paper that's
that's taking that's taking food out of
the mouths of hard-working podcasters
everywhere which I'll note now there are
literally dozens of after we blaze this
trail mm-hmm I hear you man so with with
these two different studies kind of both
coming out this month they kind of paint
a little picture for you in terms of
what you can get away with and what
probably isn't a great idea
I would say that if you want to do
intermittent fasting because you enjoy
the satiety benefits of that there's
probably a good way to do that and I'd
say the best way to do that is probably
give yourself an eight-hour feeding with
window based on this other study about
breakfast omission it's probably a good
idea to eat before you train so if you
have an eight hour feeding window and
you believe that this refractory period
after protein feedings is is worth your
time to worry about which is debatable
um then you would have a meal let's say
you start eating at noon you eat at noon
you train you eat at 4:00 you eat at
8:00 you had three quality protein meals
spaced four hours apart you're fine
mm-hmm you're completely fine now the
reason I say the protein were factory
thing may or may not be important
Yorn tromelin has has written about this
extensively he knows protein metabolism
about as good as anybody that idea that
you have to really worry about spacing
these protein meals perfectly a seam it
seems to be a little bit less relevant
in people who do resistance training
because resistance training has such a
robust and
sustained increase in muscle protein
synthesis yeah I think that um I think
that this area of literature helps
illustrate something that I don't think
a lot of people quite get yeah I think
it's something that people understand
but don't actually make a point of
thinking through and day to day life and
that is that it doesn't just matter if
something seems to have a beneficial
effect you also need to keep in mind how
large that effect is relative to other
things that you're doing so protein
feedings absolutely increase muscle
protein synthesis I don't think anyone
is going to argue with you about that
but the degree to which protein feedings
increase muscle protein synthesis is
dwarfed by the degree to which
resistance training increases muscle
protein synthesis and so if you're
wondering you know what's going to help
me build more muscle will may be spacing
protein feedings out help a little bit
yeah maybe but that's kind of like a
drop in the ocean compared to the effect
of just lifting weights so you know if
you're if you're really really focused
on your protein timing but have a stupid
resistance training program it's kind of
like majoring in the minors or if the
protein spacing is the thing you're
obsessing about versus the thing that's
actually going to give you more bang for
your buck it's kind of the same
principle and I think this is the
illustration that's used more frequently
of you know the person who knows the
supplement literature inside and out and
takes you know 40 different supplements
that could plausibly have a small
beneficial effect on performance and
then you look at their diet and they're
eating a thousand calories a day and
only getting down like 80 grams of
protein it's like well yeah I mean maybe
those supplements theoretically help but
they wouldn't help as much as just
having a decent diet in the first place
exactly
so to wrap this discussion up and get a
little bit to get some practical
applications out of it I still think
from a theoretical perspective kind of
the the default strategy the null
strategy is basically to have at least a
few meals a day and kind of spread them
out throughout the day yeah but I think
the important thing that grant study
shows us and again it's one study so no
need to to completely go nuts with it
although it is also in line with his
previous study in males that were also
resistant training so it is starting to
kind of get a little snowball rolling
where there are several studies
indicating that these time restricted
feeding protocols don't seem to have
deleterious effects when it comes to
muscle loss or the ability to gain
muscle so it may be they're not a
hundred percent optimal from muscle
accretion but if there is any detriment
it doesn't even seem to be big enough to
show up in these studies which which
really makes you pause and think about
how much you should worry about that
yeah and the the argument that I've seen
made several times is well for these you
know pretty normal resistance trained
people in these studies maybe it doesn't
make much of a difference but perhaps it
does if someone is you know seven
percent trying to get down to five
percent where you know they're going to
be in a more catabolic state generally
and so maybe for them it does make more
sense to spike MPs more frequently and
to that I would say maybe I mean we
don't have research on it and that is
that one applies to such a small
percentage of the population and to
applies for such a small percentage of
the time in that small percentage of the
population that like yeah maybe if you
want to be a little bit more neurotic
about protein timing when you're four
weeks out from a show cool but that
doesn't give you license to a you
yourself be super neurotic neurotic
about it all the time and be to try to
make other people neurotic about it yeah
I mean I don't know if we've chatted
about this but I did intermittent
fasting during a bodybuilding prep
yeah I prepped in 2013 I think and I
mean it was fine man like in terms of
lean mass it I had the same amount of
lean mass I believe is when I got my pro
card four years later and I was damn
close to a pro card in 2013 the first
show I did I want to buy a mile but we
were one competitor short of being able
to give out a WM bf Pro card I was
pretty devastated yeah I mean it's so
like I'm not saying that it made a
difference in that circumstance I'm
saying if that was an argument someone
made yeah yeah then I was just trying to
make clear that that would still only
apply in a very special circumstance any
very small percentage of people ya know
yeah and I totally agree with that but
it is kind of unique that like I did it
like I tried that exact thing and it was
it ideal I don't know but it was close
enough to get the job done yeah I think
the the reason that I sucked that prep
was I was doing way too much in really
high intensity interval training I just
trained myself into the dirt but the
fast I was a 2013 that's when everyone
was doing too much high-intensity I just
think I just exposed myself as being a
complete trend follower yeah in 2013 the
entire fitness industry was just like
headquarters all pouring out of our ears
because we were doing hit like four
times we went we were trying to figure
out what the most ridiculous exercise
you could possibly do and still call it
a Tabata was yes absolutely
those are bad times and and to get an
idea of how much it scarred me so 2013 I
was doing hit on like a daily basis I
mean absolutely killing myself hit the
next time I prepped I did
no cardio of any type I was like I'm
never doing that again
I'm out the only cardio I did is I
walked to work in the morning I walked
home at night but but in any case like I
I I've done normal feeding window preps
I've done time restricted feeding
windows
by no means a a pusher left I'm
restricted feeding I've never advocated
it to anybody but I have taken it to the
most extreme place you would want to
take it mm-hmm and I don't know if it
was optimal but it was definitely fine
and I think that's the one thing that
grants new study can can kind of give us
data to support yeah in a less extreme
application obviously now the the if you
are to apply it I still think it's a
good idea to have multiple meals two or
three you can easily fit that in a our
eight hour feeding window it's probably
a good idea to eat something before you
train some people can adapt quite well
to fasted training and it's not that big
of a deal to them but I think the the
generalized broad recommendation would
probably be that you want you want to
eat something before you train anything
to add on time restrictive being uh I
think one of the reasons why it did get
so popular in the first place I think
one of the reasons it got so popular in
the first place is that a lot of people
don't just don't want to have to deal
with breakfast in the morning so I'm
speaking for myself here I practiced I'm
restricted feeding and the biggest
reason why for me personally is I have a
pretty extreme late chronotype and
people with late Crona types tend to
wake up feeling groggy and not
particularly hungry and we just wanna we
just want to do what we have to do to
get some caffeine in our system and
start our day and the more things that
have to be added to our morning routine
the more we hate life and so when I
heard like oh you can skip breakfast and
you'll be fine that was a godsend to me
yeah and I mean so for me and I think
for a lot of people with late Crona
types
it just meshes with our personal
preferences and and I think that that I
think time restricted feeding is the
type of deal where
if there is a benefit to it it's that it
helps you just naturally consume fewer
calories but I think the biggest benefit
for most of the people who regularly
practice it is just that it meshes with
the type of lifestyle they would want to
have more so for me I hate breakfast I
love breakfast food but I don't want to
eat first thing in the morning and so
for me it makes a lot of sense if you're
someone who wakes up and you love
everything about eating breakfast that's
part of your morning ritual you have an
earlier chronotype so you wake up
feeling good and that's like the type of
thing that gets your day off to a good
start probably not for you yeah I just
want to for the record state that you
claiming to have a late chronotype is
the most egregious understand I've ever
heard in my entire life I mean so Greg
and I lived down the street from each
other essentially so I know his
day-to-day schedule and if he ever
messages me at 8:00 in the morning it's
night time yeah 8:00 in the morning
means Greg hasn't gone to bed yet it
doesn't mean he's up and at it now that
is not that's bad I shouldn't do that as
often as I do but but for me like the
daily schedule that I legitimately feel
best on and I've spent enough of my life
working online that I've been able to
experiment with with different schedules
what I legitimately feel best doing is
going to bed at 3 or 4 and waking up at
noon or 1:00 and and it's like I have
I've taken months where I go to bed at
or before midnight wake up early in the
morning like I've given myself time to
theoretically be able to acclimate to an
earlier schedule I just feel like trash
the whole time and even if I'm sleeping
well one it's harder to fall asleep and
then if I am still sleeping you know
eight nine hours a night if if I'm
habitually sleeping nine hours in
from say 11 p.m. to 8 a.m. if I have a
day that I don't have to set an alarm
I'm so sleep-deprived I sleep like 12 or
13 hours like I just get dog shits sleep
if I sleep at normal times but yeah I
mean but I don't promote that to people
because I I understand that I'm on a
pretty far extreme end of that spectrum
yeah that's not encouragement from the
podcast that's a sobering tale all right
so to play us out for this episode we
are gonna do something new we're gonna
reach into the stronger by science
mailbag and pull out a question from a
listener the question is from MW Stinson
you've written pretty extensively about
what would be good approaches for
training for beginners but what would
you say are mistakes that some coaches
make when working with beginner
recreational lifters so that's a really
good question I picked it specifically
so I know it's a good question yeah
great job Greg hell yeah and and good
job MW Stenson yeah so there are a few
mistakes people make when training
beginner recreational lifters some of
which are specific to beginner lifters
and some of which are just mistakes that
a lot of trainers make with a lot of
lifters so the first thing and this is a
pretty general one is way too many
trainers don't pay enough attention to
what their client actually wants to
accomplish a lot of trainers have a
particular type of thing they like to
train people for like maybe you're the
powerlifting guy maybe you're the
bodybuilding guy maybe you're the
Olympic lifting guy like that people
have their thing that they like to do
and it's nice and it's easy if someone's
goals line up with the type of training
you like to prescribe to someone but you
need to make sure that
that you're not just training people for
what you want them to accomplish versus
what they actually want to accomplish so
if someone comes to you and they say
like you know I want to be a bodybuilder
I want to get big and shredded and like
aesthetic and other bodybuilding words
thick fit thick solid tight tight yeah
symmetrical you know if they come to you
and those are their goals and you say
all right we're gonna squat bench and
deadlift three times a week that may not
be horrible training for what they want
to accomplish but that is not perfectly
in line with what they are trying to
accomplish that's not what they're
hiring you for they're not hiring you to
make them a power lifter and say yeah I
see a lot of coaches who get kind of
complacent and they have a system they
like to put all of their clients through
which if you have like a sports
performance facility and you're doing
group training like maybe that's what
you have to do but if we're talking
one-on-one personal training it should
be much much more tailored to the
individual client and what they're
actually trying to accomplish versus the
type of training you personally prefer
another mistake a lot of people make
very early in the process is they give
new lifters too much too soon so it's
hard for it's hard for people like us
who've been training for 10 15 plus
years to remember what it was like your
first day in the gym and to not be a
complete masochist yet so like at this
point if I have a hard workout and it's
you know maybe I do some lifts that I've
grown on accustomed to and I wake up the
next day and my hamstrings are so sore I
can barely walk and to ambulate about my
day I have to walk like a duck or
something I think that's awesome right I
love that if someone isn't into lifting
it's there
first day in the gym they don't want to
be that sore and that's gonna scare them
away because if they if if if if they do
come back for their second workout and
you tell them like ah it's fine like you
won't get sore like this all the time
one they have no idea that you're
telling them the truth they they have
not experienced their 10th workout
they've only experienced their first
workout and second they apparently had
some level of trust in you to put them
through their first workout in the first
place and whether you realize it or not
you have done something to betray their
trust most people are trying to to feel
better from working out and you just
made them feel way worse and so there's
some research on what it takes to
acclimate people to lifting to the point
that they're not going to get crazy
severe Dom's when you actually put them
through a challenging workout and it
turns out it doesn't take very much like
I think I've seen the I think what I've
seen used several times in the research
is something like 30 to 40% of a1 brett
max for a couple sets of 10 which we're
we're talking super super easy training
so the further the first time you put a
muscle group for a new lifter through a
workout it should be super simple and
and just by having one or two quite easy
sessions then when you start ramping
things up they will probably get sore
but not life-destroying sore so that's
number two number three is just loading
people way too much before establishing
basic motor skills I do think that
people can go the opposite direction of
you know playing with kid gloves with a
new client for too long and you know
they've been you're stringing them along
for three or four months before you
actually have them do real training
that's probably overboard for most
people but the opposite applies as well
if you haven't established that say they
can actually control their body weight
through a squat do it with pretty good
form maybe have a pretty decent looking
kettlebell squat like if you don't take
the time to make sure they have those
basic motor skills and if they don't
spend a little time to establish those
basic motor skills before putting a
barbell on their back and actually
loading them heavy you'll probably get
away with it more often than not
honestly because humans aren't brittle
we're not made of glass most people are
pretty robust but you are probably
unnecessarily increasing injury risk
that could be avoided by you know just
taking thirty minutes to check oh can
this person actually control their body
through the positions I want to load
them through and if not you know just
taking a week or two to make sure you
establish those basic motor skills in a
similar vein mistake I also see a lot is
introducing people to too complex of
movements really early on so here I
primarily have weight lifting variance
in mind and if someone wants to be a
weight lifter if they come to you and
they say I want to be a weight lifter
like okay you should probably start
doing technique work with a broomstick
or a PVC pretty early on with that
individual but if someone doesn't want
to be a weight lifter one you probably
don't ever need to do weight lifting
movements with them into if you do
there's a lot of low-hanging fruit you
can pick before needing to dedicate a
substantial amount of time to teaching
people those lifts before they can
actually benefit from them so if
someone's if someone's good at cleans
are good at snatches I absolutely think
that those can be movements that are
used well to develop velocity develop
power in those athletes but it takes a
pretty decent time a pretty decent
amount of time before someone gets good
enough at weight lifting movements for
you to be able to load them heavy enough
that it's actually going to have much of
training effect so that's definitely not
something that most non weightlifter and
in probably not crossfitter as well
because you know probably a fifth of
CrossFit is weightlifting but if
someone's not a weightlifter a
crossfitter you don't need to get them
into Olympic lifting probably ever and
certainly not super early on in their
training life another another mistake
that I see a lot of people make once
they have established basic motor skills
with people and you've got to gotten
them to the point that you can start
loading them is is being too
conservative with load progressions so
here the amount of trust that your
client has in you is really important so
again it can be hard to put yourself in
the shoes of someone who you know at
this point has maybe been lifting a
month you know you've been lifting ten
fifteen years you don't think twice
about throwing heavy weight on the bar
to squat or dead lifts that's not
something that scares you maybe you get
a little bit nervous for a PR attempt
but you know you've hit a lot of PRS in
your day but if someone's still pretty
new to lifting going up in weight week
to week and doing something they've
never done before in the weight room
that can still be scary and intimidating
so you need to one be able to convince
them that yes I you can put more weight
on the bar and then also this is
something I talk about a lot I think a
lot of people conceive of coaching as
can you write good programs and there's
way more that goes into coaching than
that like I would say 80% of coaching is
soft skills and being able to get buy-in
from your clients from your athletes -
when you say like hey let's go up and
wait you can one convince them that yes
you're you're good for this and they
trust you to let to let you put more
weight on the bar and I think that yeah
I think a lot of trainers
maybe focus a little too much on keeping
their clients comfortable versus
actually kind of nudging them towards
train types of training and amounts of
loading that's going to be beneficial
for them and then the last thing and
this one is huge and it relates to soft
skills if you're dealing with a
completely novice lifter the number one
tool in your toolkit is positive
reinforcement again you may not remember
how nervous you were the first time in
the weight room maybe how insecure you
were because you know you're probably
not good at any of the lifts you're
doing and there's a bunch of people
around you who are way better they
probably aren't even looking at you but
you think that they are and it can just
be it can be a nerve-wracking experience
for a lot of people and you're one of
your main jobs is to instill confidence
in your client and figure out ways that
you can correct them and teach them
while still being overwhelmingly
positive I'm aware of the research that
says you know too much positive
reinforcement can be a bad thing and I
think that that applies for you know
like intermediate level lifters maybe
they need some tough love you can't
compliment them on good form every
single set because then it ceases to be
a compliment on good form but if someone
has been training for you know fewer
than three to six months anything that
is good that you can conceivably
compliment them on do it be as positive
as possible positive reinforcement huge
huge huge for training new lifters and
on that positive note I think it's time
to end the episode we want to thank
everyone for listening now after the
music we've got an interview with Grant
Tinsley dr. grant Tinsley professor at
Texas Tech a little note about that
interview we when we were recording it
at the time his wife was pregnant I
believe that they had a daughter who is
now
eight or nine years old this interview
is payable to her for so long and we've
been sitting on this interview forever
so we talk about a whole bunch of his
research it predates it we're we had the
interview before his most recent study
had even come out yet but in any case we
talk to him about all sorts of research
he's done in the past including some on
time restricted feeding it's a terrific
interview so stay tuned after the music
and we'll see you next time
[Music]
all right welcome to the stronger by
science podcast this is eric Trexler the
director of education at stronger by
science and today i'm joined by greg
knuckles and today we are very lucky to
have a guest named dr. grant
Tinsley grant is a he's an assistant
professor at Texas Tech University he
does all sorts of body composition
exercise diet research there so first of
all grant thank you for joining us
no problem happy to be chatting with you
guys today so grant and I have met in
person at the ISSN conference a few
years ago and kind of as part of
introducing you to the audience our
first interaction made me very upset
because I was staying with grant we're
like waiting for a talk to start and
he's mentioning all these things he's
like well you know I'm trying to like
you know put a gym together in the house
and you know got the wife and kids back
home excited to be back and you know
it's tough being a you know tenure track
professor and then I found out how old
he was and I was so pissed off and felt
so useless as a human being so grant can
you give us a little idea of your
background and then time-stamping to
make us all very upset at how much
you've accomplished so young I wasn't it
yeah I wasn't expecting that that
commentary but yeah sorry for that I'm
glad that you you know decide to have me
on the podcast nonetheless but yeah I
guess I got a little ahead on the
traditional track of things probably
because I was a home schooler I was I
was homeschooled all my life so because
then I was able to start taking some
college courses when I was 15 and just
kind of knocking out some general
education credits and all of that so I
think at around 50 credit hours or so
when I started at Oklahoma State
University around 17 so I stayed there
in normal for years
I got degrees there in physiology and
nutritional sciences and and had kind of
been normal what I view as a normal
college experience after that I went did
a one-year master's program in
biomedical sciences at Colorado State
University so I just kind of made up a
year there and from there went on to to
Baylor University and did my doctorate
in kinesiology and exercise nutrition
so I'm trying to think I think I was I
guess 24 I think 24 when I accepted the
position at Texas Tech possibly turning
25 so yeah now I've just am wrapping up
my third year at Texas Tech and yeah I'm
28 now like you mentioned have a wife in
it almost two year old and another one
on the way so I'm kind of like you
mentioned I guess fully into adult life
now yeah well congratulations I didn't
know he had another one on the way yeah
we do it's a exciting times awesome so
yeah I always like to make sure that the
audience likes me more than the guests
so I try to start out by making you seem
like a jerk for accomplishing so much
now right now what would you say that
like the majority of your research is
focusing on yeah so I mean I think you
correctly identified it I'm really
interested in human body composition
sort of the the full spectrum from
physique athletes up to individuals with
say obesity or sarcopenia
obesity I've done more on the athletic
side for sure but I'm interested in in
body composition in and of itself I'm
interested in how we can accurately
assess body composition whether those
are kind of evaluating long-standing
techniques in new ways or looking at
novel methods and then of course sexual
you know modulation or changing body
composition largely increasingly mass or
decreasing fat mass so lots of issues
kind of tangentially related to human
body composition so being someone who
studies body composition if I were to
ask you to tell me your body fat
percentage you don't have to give me a
number I'm not putting you on the spot
but how would you get knowing what you
know how would you go about obtaining
the one true value for your body fat
percentage yeah so that's a great
question I'll start with a caveat that
unless I was willing to give my life and
pursue this number knowing this number
there's no way I can know my true true
body fat percentage as a living human
being at this point with that said if
you know I were again not not donating
my my body as it could have or anything
like that what I would do
would
b22 go to the lab and to build what we
call a multi compartment model or a four
compartment model in this case with a
really strict standardization and I can
explain the four compartment model in a
minute
I would do that likely a couple times in
a row
ideally maybe even like three days in a
row back-to-back if I'm being very you
know like extra precise here I would
take some other individual measurements
and kind of look at all the data and
interpret it holistically and I think
there ways to do this even without the
advanced methods but in a perfect world
how you do this would be ideally four
compartment model so this would involve
in sessemann via probably air
displacement plusses MOG Rafi or
underwater weighing to get an estimate
of my body volume I would get I'm so bad
pod yeah yeah sorry bad pod or
underwater weighing so an estimate of my
the three dimensional volume of my body
my body mass on a calibrated scale an
estimate of body water ideally you'd do
this through some advanced techniques
like a dilution technique but this would
take several hours so practically in the
lab will often use bio impedance
spectroscopy so this is a technique
similar to a Vance version of what you'd
see even in embody fat scales or little
handheld body fat devices bis is just a
little more advanced way to do that but
you can get an estimate of body water
and then I would do a DEXA scan to get
my bone mass and you can essentially
plug those components so body volume
body mass body water and bone plug those
into an equation and essentially you've
taken a lot of things into account when
you finally get this body fat percentage
so that's what I do under very strict
standardization so over night food and
fluid fast rested etc again the in a
perfect world I'd do this maybe a few
days back-to-back and average my
measurements so one of my questions that
I like to ask body comp researchers that
put them on the spot is do you think
body comp tests are are actually useful
at the individual level or do you think
their main utility is looking at kind of
group level changes that smooth out the
the error that they're prone
yeah another great question you clear
though this and the way you ask this
question demonstrates that that for all
techniques air at the individual level
is much higher than air at the group
level so like you said at the group
level the individuals who are
overestimated say in body fat by it by a
given technique will balance out to some
extent with individuals who are
underestimated with that said I think
there is some utility to tracking body
composition changes in individual you
just need to interpret them cautiously
and I would say holistically so
interpret them in the context of other
metrics that aren't even related to to
body composition directly um things like
nutritional intake performance etc would
you like me to kind of give a
recommended practical method for how I
would do that oh sure
yeah I'm all ears yeah so so practically
and you know as I talked about the multi
compartment model most of us many many
people you know listening this won't
won't have access to all this equipment
you know and won't be able to do testing
that way so in sort of a more practical
scenario and given the fact that many
body composition techniques have really
large errors at the individual level
what I would personally do in that
scenario again strike standardization
the odds are stacked against you if
you're measuring body comes just
composition and individual already so
you want to minimize any errors you can
so when I say standardized overnight
food and fluid fast if you're taking a
body mass measurement your scale at home
ideally new body weight you voided your
bladder even considered your bowel
movements if your regular I mean as
standardized as you can be so body mass
then what I would do personally is take
both circumference measurements and
skinfold estimates at kind of major
sites on the body and I'd interpret
those cautiously but you can infer some
things from those so for example if you
are in a period of your training where
you're trying to gain muscle and you're
being estimates on your thigh for
example if you see that your thigh
circumference you know measuring this to
the best of your ability
at the exact same location after the
same standardization all that if you see
that you're like circumference is
increasing and you're seeing no change
in the Ross skin fold thickness I'm at
that location you could cautiously
interpret that as you're gaining muscle
mass in your thigh without necessarily
gaining subcutaneous fat in your thighs
so I would interpret those raw
circumference --is with the raw skin
fold estimates also considering body
mass and thinking about things like your
your performance in the gym what you're
seeing and your nutritional intake so
that you don't freak out and change
something dramatically in your
programming just because you have a day
where your measurements seem to be
moving in the wrong direction
now you mentioned doing this maybe a few
days in a row if possible especially
when looking at like a 4c model how do
you factor in or should you factor in
the phase of menstrual cycle for women
yeah that's a great question I think you
should factor that in so probably with
any assessment method the ideal thing if
there is a regular menstrual cycle you
can base the Sasa
off of would be to do the measurements
at the same phase in the menstrual cycle
so that's a certain number of days you
know past the onset administra bleeding
or however you want to quantify that you
know as you know that can be more
difficult if you're talking about
physique athletes if you're doing with a
fleet who hasn't had a cycle in a long
period of time you know you don't know
exactly if there are any variations and
by foods that that aren't corresponding
to a obvious phase in the menstrual
cycle but yeah for someone with a
regular menstrual cycle I would say
that's another thing you can standardize
so standardize everything just reduce
any errors that you can so if I was you
know person in the general population
who didn't live right next to a big lab
and I can only have access to bod pod or
DEXA or bi you know only one of the
common methods out there which one would
you direct me to or would you maybe even
just say maybe don't bother
hmm that's a good question will this
testing be free for this person or not
historically not yep free yeah I mean
usually I haven't looked into it because
I've kind of always been in the lab but
I Gregg do you have any idea how much
body cop assessment typically taught
costs so typically you can get skin
folds done by a trainer in a gym
somewhere
tell them you're interested in signing
up for their services and that will be
part of maybe like the the free thing
that they would provide to entice you to
sign up so you can probably get that
done for free be is dirt cheap like you
can probably buy one of the devices for
yourself for like 20 bucks maybe 30 I
think if you want to get like a DEXA or
bod pod done though typically you're
gonna be paying between 75 and a hundred
bucks yeah yeah so in in the context of
that what I would recommend would
probably still be doing the more
practical method if you want to do that
you know even monthly could so that the
raw circumference is raw skin folds
strict body weight and then if you want
more detailed information so for example
if you want a look at regional body comp
and you're just a little skeptical of
the circumference and skin fold method
or something like that I don't think
it'd be wrong of course to pay for decks
over every so often I definitely don't
think or a bod pod I don't think you
should be doing that every month as you
guys know and likely listeners know I'm
in advantage of decks in the scenario
would be the regional body composition
output whereas something like Bob pod
and most but not all impedance devices
would be that they they just give you
whole body output you know so it might
be interesting to see like okay you know
my body fat apparently has decreased or
maybe my fat free mass has increased but
without any regional information some
people in the physique athlete realm who
are really interested in in knowing as
much as possible in fine-tuning their
training that that may not be enough
information for them so even if you do
do the more advanced testing and choose
to pay I'd recommend doing kind of the
practical testing on your own in Greg
since you mentioned having a trainer do
the skin folds
I think the ideal scenario here would be
to have like a either life partner gym
partner or someone who is kind of
willing to put in the time like you to a
small group practice on each other get
to the point where you're sure you're
getting reliable estimates I'm sure you
guys have seen this as well but but you
can have skinful measurements by someone
who's moderately trained or who seems
like they should be able to have
reliable measurements but then if you
look at how they're actually conducted
or look at the output you you know
they're just vastly off so you'd want to
same guys who's taking the measurements
you definitely won't want trainer a
taking the measurements one month and
then you know they leave the gym or
something like that and a few months
down the road you're getting the new
trainer who came in taking your
measurements so when I say standardize
everything ideally you're having the
same person take the circumference as
for you if you're not able to do them
the same person doing the skin folds for
you et cetera so that would sort of be
my recommendation on that point that's a
really good point that I often forget to
make when talking about this stuff but
like man skinfold quality varies like
Malia Malia blue is in my old lab she's
published under the name Malia Melvyn as
well before she got married but like
I've always been convinced her skinfold
measurements should be the the official
gold standard in the literature and all
other devices are just trying to catch
up to her skin folds like she was like a
wizard with the calipers but I mean
every now and then like especially like
in just a lab of kids trying to like
learn it or whatever you get some wacky
numbers so the training and the
consistency of who's doing it with skin
folds is huge and you are kind of
telling me a lot of what Bill Campbell
has told me kind of just in our
conversations which we're kind of like
whether or not you want to put a body
fat number on it is up to you but he and
I are kind of of the thought like if you
have either calipers or an ultrasound
and you're monitoring you know fat
thickness throughout a weight loss phase
or a contest prep like just measure what
you're trying to make inference is about
and that's just the fat thickness you
know yeah so if you want to like plug it
into some regression based equation that
or may not be good for you that's fine
and you can get a number and say hey I'm
nine percent body fat but really what
we're looking at is did your do you have
less fat between the skin and muscle
than you used to so it really I mean
like you're saying it doesn't have to
get too much more complicated than that
at the individual level now before we
move on I do have one question yeah I
saw you posted something on social media
I think about this new 3d imaging device
what can you tell me about that cuz like
I knew there would be a day where I had
been out of the lab game for long enough
that the world would pass me by but I
thought it would take more than four
months yeah and I'm already like what
the hell is going on in there so what
what is this 3d imaging body comp device
yeah no that's for your question I'm
happy to talk about that we actually
have four different devices in my lab
that are these infrared 3d scanners so
to the best of my understanding these
were first developed in the mid-1980s
these infrared three-dimensional
scanners essentially the purpose of
these scanners is to build a
three-dimensional avatar of the human
body
so the original purpose and these being
developed was kind of from the fashion
merchandising realm in my understanding
is for a custom fit of clothing I know a
graduate student Aria who worked at
Disney one summer and they they used all
these 3d scanners to scan him so we have
kind of the Custom Fit uniform or
costume for the performances at Disney
so that's kind of the background that
came from in the last five to ten years
they've started to slowly emerge and
more recently within the last couple
years as a method for body composition
estimation so in terms of what these
devices are actually like three of the
four scanners in my lab have a rotating
platform that a participant will stand
on the participant will be clothed
similarly to what they would do for bod
pod so minimal form-fitting clothing we
have individuals in swim caps so that's
in there just you know with their body
they get rotated around and there are a
few different technologies but
essentially infrared light is is
captured and
a point cloud is built which is kind of
a three-dimensional representation of
the participants body with these kind of
XYZ points and these are all meshed
together so you eventually get an avatar
so like you can drag this around rotate
in three dimensions and this is
someone's body kind of a funny side note
as well it students in my lab was just
presenting some preliminary research
from these 3d scanners at a conference
and he actually had a friend of his in
the engineering department 3d print one
of his own avatars so at the conference
he had kind of an action figure of his
own body that he was able to pass around
to people who came to his poster anyway
and so I mean I was I would imagine that
ultimately the end game passed costume
making is that you do the three the 3d
printing and you wait for artificial
intelligence to pick up and then we
merge that and it's pretty much all over
right yeah pretty much yeah
that's probably we're headed cool thanks
for contributing to that yeah you're
doing that I'm just hoping to be on the
right side of history here you know yeah
I welcome the AI people that will rule
us yeah I think they're great yeah so
you have these 3d avatars and what I've
described so far even in this moment of
detail probably sounds kind of techy and
they look very cool but at the end of
the day as of now these are essentially
a really fancy tape measures really
expensive tape measures because most of
the companies producing these devices
and they're around half a dozen right
now they're using them for body
composition applications most of them
are just using circumference based
equations so you essentially have like
the army body fat equation you just have
a really fancy digital tape measure and
admittedly they it's a little bit of
mixed evidence but likely that they're
more reliable for circumference
estimates then then a human with a
flexible measuring tape unless that
human is like kind of an expert tailor
but right now they're kind of
circumference based equations where
these could go would be using total or
regional body volumes to predict body
composition so if and the companies
aren't there yet but if if they can nail
down the total body volume then this
very quick scan could theoretically
replace something like bod pod or
underwater weighing even for use in a
multi compartment model
but as of now there's one company I know
of that's using a mix of circumference
--es and volumes of different body
segments to predict body fat but we're
doing some validation work for them and
there's a lot that needs to be done
before these can be viewed as a
reasonable method for a standalone
method for estimating body composition
actually a quick side note because I
know you guys might Greg you might be
even particularly interested in this
though Eric I'm sure you will too one
kind of cool thing we can do though is
it gives us so many anthropometric
measurements that I have a bio mechanist
colleague in my department he's doing a
really interesting deadlift study right
now and we're scanning every one with
this three scanners part of the study
and we'll be able to look at kind of
some advanced anthropometric predictors
of deadlift performance so there's some
other kind of sport science application
beyond just the body comp realm oh
that's pretty sweet yeah yeah you can
get I mean can you get down to like
potentially superficial bony markers or
are you looking at just like lever
lengths there which is kind of kind of
gross estimates probably more gross
estimates at this point I need to look
into a little bit on the processing the
outputs crazy the amount of output you
get from this but there's some regions
that are much easier to identify things
like the crotch and the armpit are
pretty easy to for the automated
software to identify landmarks are a
little you can do that might be a little
bit trickier so that's something we'll
have to look as we get into the analysis
on that that project yeah I would
imagine anything beyond like the patella
or you know real protrusions in the
ankle or something like that would
probably be pretty tough yeah but no
that's really cool and I would imagine
there's maybe something down the road
there where we can get more information
about different patterns of fat storage
and kind of how those predicts body fat
as well as you get into
three-dimensional kind of imaging
absolutely and they're they're actually
two big NIH studies looking at that and
they're trying to develop body
phenotypes beyond like the apple shape
and pear shape and seeing whether unique
health risks associated with certain
phenotypes well we're gonna need more
fruits yeah interesting gonna have a
whole fruit system III identify my body
shape
as has kumquat shaped in truly enough
it's a good one
do you mind if I use that I introduced
that term into the scientific literature
yeah the kumquat shaped body or like
dragon fruit like a bunch of weird
little protrusions what I like that
this isoh Lac class and sophistication
with my eating and Greg will attest to
this
I don't even know what any of those
fruits are shaped like yeah fruits or
vegetables I'm I have no idea Greg and I
always have dinner every every Sunday
night and he'll make this like super
elaborate thing I've never heard of and
he'll be like would you bring Eric and
I'm like shredded chicken again so a
kumquat is just a very very small citrus
fruit and you eat it with the skin on
weird yeah is it round it's it's over
Lloyd over the white yeah it's okay yeah
it shaped like me you without the limbs
I assume um you know what I'm working on
it I'm working on it okay it's it's less
than it's less than a kumquat describes
my current body shape and more that it
describes the body shape to which I
aspire well it's good I mean setting
goals is huge the more specific the
better you know the old SMART goal
acronym specificity is key I was trying
to think of a fruit that would be very
flattering and I found out in the
process of thinking my fruit library is
limited if it's not an apple or an
orange or a banana dude easy peasy it's
a it's a butternut squash oh yeah I feel
like that would be a flattering one for
women at least sure is it would be like
shoulders wider than the waist and then
big hips like you know I I feel like
that's it's something that wouldn't
necessarily be a good compliment now
because we haven't raised awareness yet
but one of these days you're thicker
than Ebola
oatmeal is going to be replaced by your
body resembles a butternut squash like
that it's gonna
that's gonna make people just melt well
you know we set out to do the podcast to
leave a legacy you know it's not you
know this isn't some get-rich-quick
scheme it's to leave a mark on the
zeitgeist and to kind of ensure that
when word that the names live on and so
if that's what we contribute and that's
what we contribute hell yeah and grant
I'm happy to rope you in on this you
know you're kind of err in spirit so
we'll probably you know give you mostly
credit for that really stupid idea I'm
happy to take the credit for that idea
that'll come up in your tenure review
and you'll be looking for a new job I'm
actually updating my CV as we speak
right now to increase that so before we
move away from body cop I have one last
kind of it's two questions in one so the
only research that matters is the
research done on physique athletes and
we all know this and Greg pretends it's
not true but he's wrong so you've done a
few studies on physique athletes but you
did a couple where you look specifically
at measuring and predicting their
resting metabolic rate and also looking
at their fat free mass characteristics
compared to others so these are kind of
two separate studies so I guess my
question is why did you look into these
characteristics like like what kind of
made you think this requires a specific
look versus just assuming they're normal
ish yeah so I guess to start with the
resting metabolic rate honestly I think
the seeds of this idea were probably
planted in my mind as you look at the
many sites now where you can calculate
your recommended calorie intake in your
macros etc and though often or many of
them will have kind of a note about
which resting metabolic rate equation
they're using and then you'll factor in
your activity level and so on and so
forth and I was noticing many of them
use these equations that have been
around for 50 to 100 years and when you
look back at these the papers where
these equations were actually developed
they're developed in the general
population some of them even
specifically excluded athletes so
you know as I'm thinking about that and
thinking about either a physique athlete
or an aspiring physique athlete who's
trying to get an estimate of their
calorie intake needs safer weight
maintenance so that they can you know
then enter a fat loss phase or muscle
gain phase or you know whatever it would
be I was just kind of wondering if even
starting at a accurate point at all and
of course you know then there should be
some monitoring and adjusting and you'll
hopefully if you're tracking well find
out whether or not that initial estimate
was appropriate so anyways I was kind of
thinking about that and then recently in
2014 I believe 10 1/2 and his colleagues
developed a nice generalized equation
for athletes so they took a bunch of
different athletes from all kinds of
different sports and built they
essentially examine the existing methods
kind of like the ones you see pop up in
calculators and found that those weren't
really accurate and these active
individuals and they developed their own
equations so that was great but you had
all types of athletes and very different
training practices shapes and sizes body
compositions etc so as interested in
taking a different approach in looking
specifically at more or less offseason
physique athletes and in looking at
whether these equations held up both
body mass based equations and fat free
mass based equations since you know the
the proportion of body mass that's fat
free mass in a physique athlete is you
know potentially different definitely
than the general population and even
then athletes in other sports so that's
when you where they've started yeah to
it up so that's kind of where this
started in in big picture what we found
is that virtually all the existing body
mass and fat free mass based equations
body mass based equations in particular
dramatically underestimated resting
metabolic rate particularly in male
physique athletes but most of them in
female physique athletes as well we also
looked at a couple portable indirect
calorimetry so if you didn't have a
metabolic cart in a lab where you could
have your resting metabolism tests we
were trying to validate some of these
portable methods that you know could be
taken and I know you know Eric you've
done some mobile data collection before
so you know something that you can have
that you can take to different locations
and not have everyone travel into your
lab so
we looked at those as well but
ultimately the point was to if necessary
and we deemed that it was necessary
develop a preliminary body mass base
equation and fat free mass based
equation for physique athletes similar
to the ones that we tested yeah now and
basically I believe recalling the paper
the only one that did kind of okay was
basically the Cunningham equation right
aside from the new ones you develop yeah
well yeah so the Cunningham 1980
Cunningham equation they developed in
newer one in ninety one and that one
didn't perform as well and then the ten
half
equation which was developed in active
individuals did pretty well at least
their fat free mass based equation but
the funny thing about the Cunningham
equation it did do pretty well but I
think it was serendipitous because they
excluded active individuals when they
developed their equation and then for
their fat free mass based equation they
didn't have a body comm technique they
just estimated fat free mass based on I
believe it was just body mass and age so
I mean they were just kind of you know
guessing at fast-food mass and excluding
active individuals but somehow it ended
up turning out to be like a decent
prediction equation for physique
athletes so I think it was it was kind
of you know serendipitous that that one
was fairly accurate yeah Greg and I were
talking about that a few weeks ago where
there it's like you kind of forget where
these equations come from based on well
once they kind of enter the use that
they're just a thing now you don't think
like oh that pertains to you know 30 to
40 year old females in a particular
region you know it's just once it's an
equation it's out there and you can just
use it but yeah it is kind of funny when
you look back at an equation and you
associate it with where you've seen it
generalize and then you look back to
where it came from and you're like why
would it make sense to use that in the
scenario yeah and so like if you haven't
looked into the validation studies it's
like did you really think that equation
was gonna be useful here grant do you do
you remember the the paper looking at
body composition in like estimates of
skeletal muscle mass in Ray Williams a
few months ago
um I don't recall the details I recall
the existence of the paper so one of the
small bits of information in that study
that generated a lot of discussion
understandably so was that apparently
Ray Williams is twenty four percent body
fat which like do you do you know what
the guy looks like I do yeah
okay so like what fruit would you use to
describe just so we can try to be
objective and academic Oh God I'm not
going to say anything that could be even
remotely insulting because when I when I
eventually meet the guy I I don't want
him to dislike me
for obvious reasons he's an absolute
legend so let's get that out oh yeah for
sure absolutely
but twenty four twenty four percent body
fat he is not and so there were people
discussing this and some people were
like no like there's no way that's right
and there were some people that's like
bro twenty four percent body fat just
just looks different when someone has
enough muscle mass like you just don't
understand it bro and I was like I was
interested in how did they get this
number in the first place
so I looked up the reference for the
ultrasound based formula that used and
it was in it was a formula developed for
sedentary middle-aged asian people which
you could say many things about ray but
he is not a middle-aged sedentary asian
person so i pointed out like hey this is
possibly the cause of this error here if
we assume there is error here and people
were like why did they use that formula
and i was like i don't know but anyway
yeah okay but you got to follow the
references yeah i got a fact check for
sure yeah and you know it's you know
error isn't you know it's not like they
completely botched it it's just like
maybe that's you know not the the
perfect equation that might be causing
some some confusion yeah i saw something
recently with the numbers that the comma
are just circling around
social media some draft prospect who can
remember had like they were saying yet
cameras 2% by fad something absurd in
and you see a picture of him K Metcalf
yes yeah I believe so
yeah yeah similar thing that bet number
gets out there and popularized and then
yeah that's what it is
oh yeah it was 1.9 percent on quite now
yeah that's lean that's lean isn't just
if you have a brain doesn't a doesn't
the existence of a brain put you
somewhere at around like 0.92 1.2
depending on how large you are I think
so I like all the deck says I've paid
attention to on the brain region it's
usually like the heads 18 percent body
fat or so so yeah that would pull up the
the average for the rest of the body a
little bit sick yeah I mean that's lean
I don't want to brag but I will so I did
RT a program we have to like have the
students use a handheld be ia thing and
it's fine you know it is what it is but
I used it in our little training thing
and it was about it was a few weeks
after a bodybuilding competition so I
had recently gained this was before I
was even close to knowledgeable about
not binging after a show as I gain like
15 pounds in the last few weeks and the
BIA put me at just a touch under 5% so I
usually when people say how lean did you
get I usually put it about one and a
half percent body just kind of back
calculating so you know he and I are in
rarefied air with the sub two percent
body fat but if you try hard enough and
you're not a baby you can do it but the
problem is most people don't want it bad
enough right for sure like we do that's
a that's interesting that you use baby
as an insult and a slur there I think I
think Eric is is anti is an anti Naida
list that's that's no intelligence for
the public defender of that's slanderous
for you to say that it's it's I think
our leaders for you to use a baby as an
insult
I had let it fly but now that Greg
points it out yeah do you care about the
propagation of our species because it's
like I was on a plane yesterday okay and
there was indeed a person a few years
behind me a person of not many years and
this person was quite boisterous and
disruptive and so maybe I'm harboring
some resentment because I really would
have loved a nap on that airplane but
the noise level precluded that so grant
I know you have one on the way I'm very
sorry if you want to if you want to hop
off the call you can I understand no
it's all good it's all good with just a
validate would you say that babies
complain or make whining related sounds
more than the general population you
know I think there's a lot of individual
variability honestly my son who's almost
2 I think complains a lot less than most
the adults I interact with in general
society but that's not true of everyone
so yeah I'd say lots of inder
inter-individual variability there well
I can tell you this so little known fact
about me is that as a child I had a
fairly moderate case of Tourette's
syndrome and I was not a pleasant baby
to be around and I can promise you that
it was there's nothing I could do to
repay my parents for just putting up
with me so I apologize to them every
time I see them and they just shake
their head and say it's it's really not
enough you you were horrible so so maybe
I'm just reflecting my own baby related
antics so we've got grant Tinsley on the
line and you can't end a discussion with
grant without saying something about
intermittent fasting you did a lot of
really really good work on intermittent
fasting do you have any in the works
right now or have you kind of moved on
toward the body composition line of
research yeah I do have some of the
works I find it a really interesting
topic the the studies are very demanding
to conduct so that won't be my you know
my only line of research I pursue
or else I just won't be as productive as
I would like to be just because the time
and effort involved for one intermittent
fasting study is much greater than half
a dozen methodology studies it feels
like to me so we do we have one major
one in the work that's under review for
publication right now it's actually a
sort of a follow-up study to the so
called League lean gain studies that we
did in males so the the 16 8
intermittent fasting we conducted a data
collection here at Texas Tech using a
relatively similar protocol in females
so we did this in in resistance trained
females they were not at the like elite
physique athlete level but had on
average about 5 years of resistance
training experience and we did you know
fully supervisor resistance training 8
weeks of the 16 8 or controlled diet we
didn't you know kind of a variety of
things they were looked at a bunch of
different markers so that's under review
and that's something that I'm really
excited about I think it will provide
some interesting information we did
protein supplement and all the groups
and had them up at a protein intake
that's that's in the range that's
optimal for lean mass accretion and one
of the main things were looking at is
whether or not there would be any
attenuation of lean mass accretion with
all calories consumed and it ended up
being about a 7 and 1/2 hour window each
day as opposed to about 13 and a half
hours each day in the control group so
yeah I'll you know definitely more to
say about that when it's when it's
published and you know maybe can can
chat in detail with you guys about that
but that's kind of the main one in the
works and then you know just because
this was a relatively unexplored area
I've been able to get pulled in on data
collections occurring at several other
universities kind of in these these
studies of intermittent fasting and
active individuals and and whether or
not this compromises adaptations or
whether or not you know who it's a good
strategy for essentially you know I
without spilling the beans on this paper
that that is forthcoming one of the
things I like to do talking to
researchers who've done multiple Studies
on a topic is you know I don't really
want you to tell me the p-value of one
statistical test of one paper you did I
like to get an idea of like what is your
general conclusion
there you know you're working kind of
operational conclusions about a
particular strategy you know so don't
tell me about one study but you know
kind of show me the forest not a single
tree within it so as a person who's done
multiple studies on interment at fasting
if I were coming to you saying grant I
have you know strength or physique
related goals is in a minute fasting the
strategy for me is it better than a
normal eating pattern what would you
tell a person like that yeah I would say
it's not inherently better I would say
it's better if it's more sustainable for
you and I know you know physique
athletes in some ways are different than
general population for the general
population say for weight loss like you
I mean it has to be something this
sustainable long term if you want weight
loss and weight loss maintenance and you
know when someone in general comes to me
and asks about it it's very much in that
realm of if you're interested in it try
it if you think you could do this
forever stick to it if not you're not
missing out it's okay
in the physique athlete realm I think
there's some people that just like have
the the willpower and the drive and just
like will do whatever is necessary so I
know it's a little bit different
population but yeah I would my big
picture answer that to that would be if
you don't want to you certainly don't
have to I think there's growing evidence
it's a viable strategy and at at least
up to intermediate training levels would
not inherently compromise performance or
lean mass adaptations so yeah I would
view it as as a strategy but not the
strategy and option but you're not
missing out on the greatest thing ever
if you don't do it and I think there
probably are some potential health
benefits that are still being explored
maybe even in isocaloric situations
independent of body weight or body
composition changes but but strictly
from like a performance and body comm
standpoint I would view it at this point
very much as an option but not the
answer yeah I'm kind of grateful it came
along because I am lately just like
the worst person on the planet and very
lazy so I just don't feel like spending
the time to eat in the morning
yeah and I'm at a unfortunately a high
enough body fat that I don't really get
hungry anymore so I just don't eat all
day and then at the end of the night I'm
like no this was good I'm intermittent
fasting yeah I'm proud of me for
sticking to my plan today yeah but yeah
I just it's fine it is what it is yeah
that's just kind of what I do do you
think that's because we stay up to
inappropriate times like super late at
night I don't know for for me personally
I am I generally have a lot to do and so
anytime in the morning before I get on
work like it makes me antsy right so if
I know I have a ton of work to do I just
want to get right at it and so I don't
want to like spend the time to cook and
eat because it makes me at least
somewhat anxious so yeah that's probably
that's it's probably a window into my
psychological health that will will lead
people to think I'm a little bit crazy
but yeah I think that's I think that's
probably why I do it more than anything
and then once once I have like a good
chunk of work done for the day I'm like
okay now I can take a break and eat
something and then once most of my work
is done for the day it's like okay now I
can take another break and eat something
else and yeah yeah that's kind of what I
base my meal schedule around
I was chuckling because I never put two
and two together but that's exactly why
I do it as well I this second I roll out
of bed I immediately begin writing and
right for at least a few hours or at
least reading but if I don't do that I'm
just a mess of anxiety and Antonis so
grant at least when you're when you're
bringing in participants for your
studies be like hey just get busy in the
morning write an article or something
and they'll love it yeah no I mean it's
true honestly it's a similar pattern I'm
you know out of bed in the office and
you know whether it's collecting data
writing whatever you look
and it's midday and you've gotten kind
of just absorbed in work so so similarly
I think is something that's really good
for certain people's schedules and
lifestyles but it would be hard if
you're just kind of like sitting around
doing nothing to wait until some certain
time of day yeah and and and that that
is the thing like I very rarely take
days just completely off work but the
days I do I I tend to either make myself
breakfast or like go out to brunch with
Lindsay or something like that
yeah my so I intermittent intermittently
fast I would say probably 90% of the
time and just as sue as soon as I kind
of break away from my normal schedule
where I'm like working from the second I
get out of bed then it's like yeah let's
go eat breakfast just because how else
are you gonna spend the morning you know
yeah yeah speaking of schedules one day
at a different time we got to wrap up
here but we need to figure out how grant
does what he does because if you look at
grants list of publications on PubMed
which everybody should grants one of the
few people out there that like all of
his studies are remarkably applicable to
the powerlifter of the bodybuilder but
grant all of your studies came out in
the last like three years man like you
need to take a nap or something this is
crazy
are you working like 90 hours a week I
don't keep track I don't think it's 90
hours a week and I appreciate those kind
of words no I mean honestly I'm really
thankful for the the faculty spot I mean
we have a very reasonable teaching load
I feel like Icahn dedicated a lot of
time and effort to research and solve a
balanced life and I spend a lot of time
every day playing with my two-year-old
and get to lift and and spend time with
friends and family and all that so I I
don't know I don't know it's a just kind
of in a good season I am very into
efficiency and try not to have wasted
time so I think that's you know it any
fad there was in my schedule definitely
got trimmed out once once we had Titus
my son so no I appreciate appreciate the
kind words well yeah that is awesome and
keep it up man because every time you
publish I mean it's like all of your
papers there's something if
Stream Li it goes right from the page to
something you can apply really directly
so thank you for doing what you do work
a little harder if you could get out
maybe 10 or 15 a year then it makes my
job a lot easier I will do my best yeah
so you know stop doing all these
podcasts you're wasting time no I know
so grant thanks so much for coming on if
our listeners want to learn more about
you or get in touch with you is there
anywhere for them to do that yeah so
probably a couple places one I will try
to post and we have just kind of
interesting things going on lab or
publications that come out or things
like that so a prime most active on
Instagram so my handles just grant
underscore Tinsley TI NS lu i underscore
PhD i'm also post some of the same
things to facebook so it's just you know
my name grant Tinsley and then have a
personal website that's relatively
static it's kind of like a CV and list
of publications though I do have
pictures of like the equipment my
laboratory and post a few resources on
there and that's just grant Tinsley comm
so those are probably the best places to
get in touch with me awesome so if
you're listening go check out Grant
social media he puts out a lot of
interesting stuff and go read his
studies because they're very good grant
once again we want to thank you for your
time and we want to thank everyone for
listening absolutely thanks for having
me thanks for listening to the stronger
by science podcast now Greg and I are
not experts in medicine or health or
really anything else for that matter so
before you make any changes to your diet
and exercise habits make sure you check
with a doctor or another health care
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it visit
stronger by science com2 check out the
products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
you